britney spears legal battle it looks
like she is set to take a huge step
towards getting back control of her life
[Music]
i just want to be a happy person
britney's attorney is reportedly set to
present legal documents requesting an
end to her conservatorship
the singer who's vacationing in hawaii
posted a video claiming the paparazzi
are photoshopping their images of her
quote i definitely do not look like how
they portray me
back in l.a brittany's father jamie
filed a request that the court
investigate the allegations his daughter
made in her testimony
in addition he claims he's just been
overseeing brits finances and is not to
blame for all the restrictions on her
personal life in the last two years
will you be taking over the conservative
ship for jamie he points out jody
montgomery has been britt's personal
conservator since 2019 and montgomery's
attorneys released this statement
on her behalf today quote it is her
sincere personal wish
that brittany continues to make
meaningful progress in her well-being
so that her conservatorship of the
person can be terminated my prediction
will be is that she will be released
from this conservatorship
we sat down with celebrity addiction
expert dr drew pinsky
who says brittany merely needs to point
out her 13-year track record on the
conservatorship
including a successful concert tour and
vegas residency
once you've established a period of
stability it's time to try
a lower level of intensity of services
meaning how about we get off the
conservatorship
if that happens how could britney who
has struggled with mental health issues
be set up for success if i were the
judge i would want to see a report every
six or 12 months that she's doing well
and we should sort of reevaluate these
things over time the clinicians could be
ready to sort of help her
if things start to unravel it's not
necessarily going to go well if she gets
off conservative in fact i suspect it
will not
but she deserves a chance at it enough
[Music]
already
you